- good morning everybody
the host of the h3 podcast ethan klein
and of course joined with me is my
beautiful co-host and wife best friend
lover and helper my son Beau Owen how
have that never gets old thank you for
joining us
do you know you could be anywhere
watching anything you might even be in
school instead of paying attention to
teacher whatever it is you're doing I
thank you for being here with me today
you could be burying a body and this is
what you're doing there's something to
just distract yourself during the work I
appreciate you for listening to me as
well every view matters and no matter
who it is happened to be listening you
know I'm not sure I'll take and I'm sure
I don't know yes Allah knows very well
today's episode is sponsored by privacy
and yours truly Teddy fresh now quickly
I want to show you guys what's new we
had a new collection yesterday Teddy
fresh calm I'm going to show you very
quickly the TF hoodie now in three
colors white teal and black you got a
new to Ted's are better than one sweater
it's just math folks you see better than
one in blue and black you've got the TF
long-sleeve teal white black this is
what I'm wearing right now I love this
shirt so much it's a striped rainbow tee
with a bare patch you've got it in black
and you've got it in cream it's all
happening folks you've got the bear
patch classic T bear patch multicolored
rib it's all happening folks you got
purple light teal dark cream circle bear
t I designed this so everybody buy this
obviously mm-hmm and then introducing
women's tees this is a crop cut both of
these are crop cut for no no it's not
super short no it's it's not a belly
shirt yeah it's not a belly shirt it's
just shorter than the men's t-shirt yeah
it looks great
we've got the pants we've got a belt a
fresh belt we've got the patchwork
hoodies and two colors sunset and
sunrise it's all happening right here
right now on the a street podcast live
we should change them to the AC podcast
live not live not like my podcast either
not podcast not good well listen enough
with the BS we're here to be entertained
because TGIF let's have some fun let's
start it off right with the video that I
personally couldn't believe is real but
I'm afraid to say it is this is the
barbershop video I always wonder what
goes on zip barbershops you know cuz I'd
never go to a barbershop and apparently
apparently this is what goes on at
barbershops no I'm trying to figure out
what's with this cut you can first of
all at the hairline that he gives this
guy is so outrageous I think he has a
receding hairline so the guy was like I
want to try to make it look like you
don't have a receding hairline and so he
cut the hairline way back instead and
now and he doesn't stop and the homie is
just trout thing is like taking deep
breaths
what is happening guys I got bad news I
don't think it is what they'll do you
know I recognize that guy the guy
getting their hair cut okay who is he
it's the guy that go back to the Twitter
post okay Twitter world Simpson go to
that guy's profile guy yeah I don't
think that's him I looked look through
all the videos this is the same dude
alright so it's so funny as [ __ ] wait
hold on hold on hold on that is him the
mother of Christ
mother of right commodity honestly
oh you got you got hit with this now got
it huh
so wait so wait eye contact do you guys
not communicate yeah that's what I'm
wondering
we don't have immune how are we not in
the same game why did you wait I didn't
see this video it's at the top of my
pocket is the first video alright well I
apologize please what's going on here
this guy is really funny though yeah
we'll give him that oh he said close
your eyes anything went through her
phone I got to check out this guy he's
guy got a piece by guy well you got me
good and even though it's a sketch I
have to applaud you because frankly so
bizarre what tipped me off was like the
perfectly frame shot yeah it looks so
real like I don't know everything about
this is just perfect
yeah props to this guy man he looks so
depressed man and that barber so he's
just so serious about it yeah this is
[ __ ] awesome man I wanted this video I
want to get a haircut like that but he's
so good acting yeah well I gotta I got a
prop I gotta give you props my dude at
mister guy a a guy a piece by guy he's
it verified he's verified that's what
I'm saying
oh ok I don't know what he's from I'm
just making [ __ ] on Twitter I guess he
said my parents split when I was in the
2nd grade but didn't get a divorce until
I was in college that is unusual I agree
no wonder this guy's thank you he's got
an Instagram day I'm gonna check this
guy's got rules look any he's even got
the comedy bars to [ __ ] tie it all
together is this dude really trying to
take a picture it's really like this
dude is like kind of act like he doesn't
know who it is
oh that's good this guy's gold man we
like what we see all right let's get him
on the podcast so a next stop we have a
very contentious video that we really
need to get Ian to weigh in on so Kayne
was caught let me show you this video
somebody candidly recorded Kanye West
eating his ear wax and I swear to you
right now
you can see clothing for the ear and
then into the mouth what's happening
what's happened what is happening here
let's watch one more time
Kanye into the ear try to defend it I
dare you as I'm sure you will oh it's
incredibly easy to defend as fake news
so obvious okay go home
okay there's a couple elements here that
you can break down mm-hmm
that's full lobe grab there's no ear
canal penetration happening that's true
I didn't know that what a worldís keeps
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up with these videos go
ahead keep going well look he good I
can't watch videos on Twitter we're
gonna start ripping these in like wine
generation or what's up with my browser
I don't know we gotta we gotta solve
this issue yeah see it's not letting me
play it that's not happen anywhere else
yeah so weird it's always when you
fullscreen it yeah it's got a
full-screen net well oh you know what I
got to do is just like this oh there you
go oh it doesn't yeah all right you know
what I'm done with Friday I was in a
good mood I was raised a jam have fun
this is outrageous how am I supposed to
watch videos Ian go ahead and now Isaac
whip well look at the ear grabbe's
doesn't go in his finger does not go
inside his ear well it looks like it
could see okay so there's the lobe but
then there's the bucket like the kind of
here's the other thing and he may
have been swooping above the low because
frankly in let me break this down for
you if you're eating your earwax in
public you want to make it look like
you're just scratched you you are hiding
it so what I know you're gonna say is
he's just touching his earlobe and then
he's taking something out of his mouth
if I was eating my earwax in public
that's what I would want it to appear
like in I get what you're saying but I
disagree wholeheartedly I gotta say I
got a piece so why would it go from ear
to mouth unless he was trying to taste
it
do you know where's the doctor though
look say you were digging in your ear
for earwax you're gonna go one finger he
uses a distinct pinching pattern that is
not conducive to retrieval that's not
truly ant because if you're digging in
this canal I I acknowledge he didn't go
into the ear but if he's doing like this
do you sue digs with two fingers that's
a clear ground like this do you see what
I'm doing
you can reach ildren or something from
that like that because sometimes you get
gunk here and you can make sometimes you
also get gunk here either you wear
earrings absolutely that happened to me
but he's doing like this so he could
certainly be scooping from the bottom
not inside but the bottom but I'm saying
you can scoop also from here he was any
and dust Konya where it's not earwax
it's no well whatever the grocery he
does he wear earrings ever no I let's
use to contine hearing I think I'm gonna
find pictures of him wearing earrings
dude no you won't
I said 2019
okay let's try 2019 big shot I got a
piece so bad ya know those years look
pretty uh earring list I gotta say it
yeah what a shocker okay I guess wife
what but maybe
is wearing it privately I don't know the
are you with him definitely I think he's
right sir he doesn't wear earrings in
the year 2019 I'm gonna give her but I'm
not because like let me get let me give
you an anecdote sometimes if I scratch
my balls I'll smell my hand and
obviously that's embarrassing you don't
want to Shh
you don't want because basically you
have to go right away you can't so if
you scratch you want to sniff you don't
want to delay but obviously you don't
because it's obvious you're like like
that so what you would do is be like
wait a second and be like oh I'm itching
my nose or something and then you're but
you're actually smelling it right so
that's what Kanye is doing in my opinion
he's trying to pull it off but in
actuality he's scoping and then he goes
straight to the mouth like hello why
would you do that and he rubs his
fingers on his tongue he's getting the
flavor dude
so I already I think I debunked the
first part of it but the second part is
the you're saying it's a delivery
yeah the mouth yeah I think that's a
very clear retrieval mode that's that's
where he's fooling you why would he go
directly from ear to tongue he grabs his
tongue he wipes the flavor of his of his
ear on his tongue dude
sounds like you have a clear advantage
from experience exactly Ian do you
scratch your balls and smell your hand
well then well then you're out of your
element you may know Kanye but I know
human nature balls in the earwax
completely different ballgame it's not
the same it's the same primal urge to
smell your your brand as it were I'm not
into ear wax or boogers or anything but
some people like that
I personally scratch my balls and smell
it no are you proud I'm not proud I'm
just using it to support my thesis I'm
just using the tools at my disposal my
and my knowledge my experience in this
life to support the thesis that I think
Kanye's tasting his earwax do you ever
smell your earwax
never yes I do frequently yes because
will this [ __ ] behind my ears is like
really weirdly smelly they clean it a
lot as much as
one can't possibly but it's got a super
strange funky smell yeah but I could see
Kanye Tate wanting to taste it look if
he was eating his earwax I and I
believed it sure I would get on board
and probably eat my own earwax and
solidarity all right but I think that
this is misleading and false you think
rattori retrieves flicks that's all
there is to it do you think it's the
flama tour yes I think people are what
is he retrieving though gum gum or a
piece of hair there's no God that's
probably a piece of hair on it [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] dude that where Emma T is
just to bro look at delivery that's a
delivery well you know that's right now
I could see it both ways honestly when
when Ian explains his I can see what are
you saying but then when you're
experiencing five steps in so I can see
it both ways I'm right it's a very this
is a guy who has been in the public for
decades now this is the first footage if
he's aching to dig he's training using a
secondary footage he's trained at the
skies get this footage isn't supposed to
exist as candid footage of the man in a
vulnerable moment we have hundreds of
hours of footage maybe it's time to
start looking back at it you can try dan
what are you fighting in here was that
Dan exact weigh in on my eye I got to
agree that I think we need more evidence
and I invite everybody in he listens to
this podcast to scour through all of the
Kanye footage and send us some
follow-ups here because I would love I
would love for Ethan to be proven right
anything wait why yeah because just to
get to you basically
so bad look I gotta sorry go ahead
no jump yeah yeah I good I think he is I
think he ate his earwax totally I think
so I think he's that type of person yeah
I mean the guy's building [ __ ] domes
of course he would eat ado yeah and and
the proximity it doesn't make sense like
okay if you're snagging some have you
ever met anyone that is into tasting
never I've never heard of it that's a
weird one but let me explain something
to you in if you know you have something
in your mouth you're gonna take that out
before you touch your ear that's true he
went to the ear to the tongue directly
otherwise he would have gone from the
ear white wiped and then removed but the
fact that he went ear mouth he could
have gone mouth wipe ear could it be he
was storing something in his ear yet wax
may be a drug of some type what in our
stretchin come on
now that's defamatory now that's the
person that thinks he was eating his own
earwax see what everyone send me your
footage of Kanye doing this again along
with photos of him where because it's
not gonna understand you sound so
confident link do you but have some kind
of secret footage
let's move on I think we've we've killed
that secret access
yeah no well Ian does have a perch from
which he watches Kanye's house with
binoculars I wouldn't be surprised in
the least but if he if he did do that
Ian you have anything that I can't
confirm okay well looking forward to
possibly dubbing much deeper into that
we have a new scooter meme on deck this
is we should give an update about the
Gatsby don't you think absolutely or the
Gatsby was supposed to arrive yesterday
and they tried to deliver it on a huge
semi-truck it didn't fit in our
buildings parking lot and they and then
they're like oh we couldn't deliver
you have to come pick it up I'm like
[ __ ] I'm ordering a mobility scooter
what makes you think that I can come
pick up my mobility scooter did you
think exactly like ironic that is who's
gonna drive my ass over there you know
so apparently we're supposed to get it
next week right down on Tuesday which is
that's that's the plan for now just such
a shame yeah it really is
we had some Google well war for today
where we were pumped we were ready yeah
it's fine well we'll we'll have them on
Tuesday but here's something to keep us
lubed up until then I got a new scooter
me which is a pleasure I feel like we
scooted we exhaust excuted we exhausted
all the scooter memes so enjoy it
cleared it I'm overjoyed to have in the
fresh one
here it is your viewing pleasure great
quality later and a woman going down not
sure why or how yet she attempted to
confound an escalator on a mobility
scooter and predictably
boy well she did go down that's true
does she just get up like a limo
afterwards because that's part of the oh
jesus walks it off beeps the record is
cool all right lady I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're expecting I mean clearly
she's never done that oh my god that's
just a physical impossibility I'm not
sure what would possess someone to think
that would be possible
it's just something about once you sit
in that's good or like the logic of the
word changes mmm you know right physics
is not the same anymore right yeah
that's true I don't know scooter people
even make it a date
like I'm surprised they aren't going all
just parish should the moment take it on
the scooter so there you go
blasting on ahead the dog abuser that we
spoke about remember the girl who spit
on her dog well the police looked into
her and they will not be filing charges
by the way I could have chucked lettuce
Philly D thumbnail cuz I'm in it I'm
like what the [ __ ] that I do I love one
feel ID clicks bait me it makes me feel
like um it makes me feel good like that
that I can pull in views story cuz I
said I wanted it to it does your dog yes
that's a very yeah to be fair I'll do
that on the podcast
I'd be like I'll be like what's our
favorite clickbait I'll be like uh Bella
Oh - did you hear that Bella Delfina
[Music]
farted on her hand and smelled it well
that'd be a big story but anyway oh yeah
yeah yeah and anyway we got item no and
you briefly mentioned her and you put
her face in the thumbnail you get you
know yeah but um shout-out to Philly D
okay so they said there's no abuse so
let me let me read some some updates for
you how do you check they looked at the
video la LAPD officials opened an
investigation but I've since decided
that there's not enough evidence support
charges against her the video showed we
know what the video showed we saw the
apology after the footage went viral
LAPD officials said their animal cruelty
task force was investigating but now
according to reports from BuzzFeed news
the most credible source of news on the
Internet police have decided not to
press charges animal task force looked
into the matter obviously they saw the
video the public had seen they
determined it didn't rise to the level
of animal cruelty
TMZ also cited the LAPD source who said
there wasn't enough evidence of support
criminal charges house was allowed to
keep custody of the dog throughout the
investigation but LAPD of fish
said they would reopen her case if new
evidence was ever presented here's some
reactions by the way pretty pretty
vicious mm whether it's just foot or not
let's let's discuss but Brooke the
police department forgave you but
remember the internet never forgets
in every generation that is access to
the Internet we'll know who you are dog
abuser
so tag Brooke House isn't being charged
with animal beus but let's never forget
that she hits and spits on her dog
that's how she'll always be remembered
in known [ __ ] the LAPD [ __ ] Brooke house
and [ __ ] anyone the defense her smacking
spitting on and pinning your dog on the
ground while you yell in its face is not
being a dog parent i teaching your dog
do not exhibit bad behavior go to a
[ __ ] dog training class well that
one's not that bad actually workouts
will not be criminally charged for
animal abuse what a travesty what she
did was absolute trash she deserves to
lose her dog and be behind bars
Burke House will not be punished for
abusing her dog video proof she spit on
the dog yelled the dog hits the dog and
pushes the dog this is clear eventually
she gets away what the actual [ __ ] in
this country the system is a failure so
I mean do you guys let me do a little
fitty let me throw it back onto you guys
what do you guys think there's this rice
I'm actually asking you guys in the
office not our audience like I'm not I
could give a [ __ ] with all this thing
yeah I mean I don't and I don't know the
law well enough to know this is not an
interactive show we talk and you guys
listen right I guess I'm just saying cuz
all the time at Philly dudes like he
doesn't give an opinion and then he goes
but what do you guys think but he
doesn't read the comments there's no way
variability reads every single comment
not that I'm shocked I don't I'm not
trying I'm not going to trash Billy but
I'm not gonna sit here in st. and I
pretend
is interactive yeah some point Twitter
fall exactly we do Twitter polls me by
the way we're buying the Gatsby that was
Brandon's wishes yeah I don't know to
far I all feel is being apology meant to
do Laurie gods
TGIF Fridays I really everybody's
apologize I will read all of your
comments tell me what you think actually
that's right in Philly accuses two I
replied to something they said with the
sup video and he said we're bullying my
point is is that if you leave a comment
there's probably I care what you think
leave a comment telling you were asking
for our opinions dog should she be in
jail should she have her dog removed I
mean it's it's a tricky thing the thing
is is that if if they took her I don't
think she should be in jail for it and
if they took her dog away the dogs going
to the pound and probably getting
euthanized you know what I mean like I
guess because it was such a public thing
it's more likely that somebody would
adopt the dog but um but yeah I mean
that statement that it doesn't rise to
animal abuse I mean like what do you got
to do - he's an animal Wow like punching
it in the face is pretty it's a tough I
agree with you that it's a little it's
kind of more nuanced because there's
being a dog a bad dog owners one thing
but like for example Ricky Gervais
always shares these stories of an abuse
like they're huge shared a story of
smoke burning a cigarette out on a
puppies I animal people are so cruel to
their animals I can't see that's nice
got a new dog a little afraid oh we
adopted him he's like a 1 year old white
Yorkie he was at the pound we were so
lucky to have swooped up on this cute
guy he's been with those 3 days he is so
precious he's so sweet
he was so mistreated he was so on
kept for he was so underweight this poor
guy he's just so sweet and so beautiful
on such a soft gentle soul what is it
people are so cruel to these like just
pure creatures it's just evil imagine
putting a cigarette out on a puppy's eye
I mean what emptiness is inside your
soul man it's terrifying and it happens
a lot there's a lot of evil people who
torture animals so unbelievable to me so
yeah that's a whole other level to what
we saw with her definitely it's a whole
different level and as Dan pointed out I
mean I really doubt this dog would be
better it's hard to say what would
happen you know as dog owners I can't
imagine treating our dog the way she did
so I don't know it's very weird to me to
be like that but at the same time like
it like you said it's not like extreme
abuse but it's not good behavior you
know and I think and I'm really hoping
that as a result of this she's coming
I have very healthy wake-up call that
she needs to get some help yeah with her
anger problems because that girl is not
not healthy of the of the mind didn't
spirit to be lashing out at a dog like
that mm-hmm
I mean dogs are pure of heart and soul
like up like a newborn child you can't
if she'll I shot her dog like that she
lash out a child like that and I think
and not that there should never be a
time that you should inter dog but I
think it's telling to the dog really
wasn't doing anything like it was just
being a little rambunctious
oh no the dogs I mean like a dog was
fighting or like do anything crazy
the dog was exhibiting behavior that she
was conveying to it that she wanted
right yeah they were playing and the dog
but so the dog was enormous it it it
dwarfs her so the dog actually never
even took her acts of aggression as
anything but her playing - which was
kind of probably that frustrates her
luck I think
I think in like a way that made her more
irritable in a bad way mmm that like the
dog doesn't even take her on its own
master seriously and she doesn't know I
had that she's not equipped to handle a
dog like that it's got a huge super high
energy dog in a tiny apartment that's
why I propose to adopt the dog but if it
were to go be taken from like animals
services I'm not sure that's a better
alternative I know I will give the dog a
happy home but if it went to the pound
that's just a trauma that you don't want
to animal to experience definitely a big
responsibility especially if you're
gonna take a big dog dude day little dog
require a lot yeah like two hours of
exercise every day or they'll get super
destructive and real and restless well
at any rate she got off the hook I do
think she must have learned something
from this so this must have been a good
lesson to her she needs to get in
therapy quick and she needs to yeah I
would say this is a big wake-up call I
wonder if she's making videos so there's
no way right let's check like how like
we were saying how does Jared come back
how does she come back cuz this is video
evidence people are debating Jared did
this chair did that this girl spit on a
[ __ ] dog on camera dude looks like
that uh no I don't think she's uploaded
since that video doesn't look like how
great is that that's all her and her
best friend dog videos I don't know it's
a tough one man I love the irony of that
thumbnail with help me I'm with a dog
yeah yeah it's really tough it's a
Doberman dude did you really have to get
a Doberman like now here look at this
guy this is a tiny little Yorkie this
guy is so freakin hard to handle and I
know he looks sweet and cute but he's
such high energy he is so rampant hi
I mean dude this guy if we don't play
with him like an hour a day at least
he'll just go mental
even then we take him to the dog park
and you'll be tired for an hour after
and then like he's recharged he's ready
again if we're just trying to sit and
watch TV he'll stand and just bark at us
and cry and it's like oh I have to you
know anyway I'm not sure how I feel
about this you guys tell me in the
comments
I wish Philly D which would tell me what
he thinks about it am I out of line
should I apologize to Philly do four
going I do
ish I did issue an apology I saw Twitter
he started calling his fans dumb [ __ ]
I swear to god he's not doing beautiful
bastard day he's just calling his fans
what's up down the [ __ ] she's always
threatening to punch them that's the
context she said what's up you dumb
[ __ ] well let's take a break when we
come back do we say enough about the dog
thing I mean we didn't really come to a
conclusion
there isn't a conclusion I mean the
authorities made their conclusion and
that's that yeah did they make the right
call they never responded leo by a she
never responded I know she read it was
so weird she reached out and she said
hey do you have time to talk I said yeah
of course
but she never followed up which is just
so so interesting I wonder what I wonder
what I think she was panicking and then
panicking again about talking to you and
then she realized it was all [ __ ] and
I just disappeared I wonder if she
lawyered up and she realized that I
would criminal stuff if I was Scott Spit
yeah I mean i cuz if she did her lawyer
probably said stop talking to everybody
actually man yeah I did they make the
right call
well I'll say this it's so
I don't think she should be charged
that's I don't think that I think
probably they it's a tough call
it's a tough call cuz it's in but I'm
not out I just not out what you did is
not like the extreme yeah
level so it's hard to determine one way
I think what they look at is like is she
inflicting like permanent damage on this
dog physically like is this dog's eye
burned with a cigarette is it cut up is
it shot with BB guns is it scared of the
owner like for example when you look at
it abuse dogs yeah they'll they'll uh
move away from the owner at times or if
you do like this they'll yeah they're
all scared and so that so you know they
have metrics and they probably gotta
weigh their options I guess they prefer
to live in with her than take which it
applies which is really nice that
they're thoughtful enough to think about
things from a actual you know human
standpoint and not just being like
alright dogs gone you know yeah I'd like
to think that they are more thoughtful
than that not tonight
that's it that's all there is
we've got jeremy renner app this is just
such a bizarre story this actor Jeremy
Renner made an app for his fans and it's
just him it's like Instagram but he's
the only one on it and it's all like you
can like pay money to get acknowledged
by him and then it got hijacked by all
these trolls and he had to shut it down
outrageous YouTube crackdown on kids
content that's - YouTube is changing
forever after this one and so much more
you do not want to miss this goof and
gas-filled episode let's go to that
break and we'll be right back
privacy dot-com is this beautiful
service
that allows you to generate credit-card
numbers so that you can make purchases
online that are connected directly to
your bank account because let me list
all the reasons why that's a good idea
how about credit card theft how about
identity theft how about every time I go
and buy a first suit or something crazy
from China I'm worried that they're
gonna steal my ID my credit card and use
it for online sex but at any rate let's
avoid suspicion and doubt all together
because privacy calm is that easy secure
way of keeping tabs on your credit cards
never get charged again for reoccurring
stuff keep track on all your funds this
is you giving you full control and full
privacy it's in the name folks here's
how it works you sign up privacy calm /
h3 you get five dollars for free from
using our code and you make virtual
cards here a Theodore's card for example
you gets $100 a year that's generous
Theodore's don't complain see look for
example mom obviously no limits whoa
whoa whoa no limit hold the thong
alright I got it I got it work and look
how easy it is to make a new card this
one's for shredder and he obviously is
gonna get a No Limit I mean No Limit for
shredder 100 okay fine great card now
shredder it's a credit card number and
expiration data security code it's all
happening for shredder now let's hop on
over to Amazon and here we are we're
buying some dog food buying some dog
treats we're gonna click this button
here select whatever one you want
shredder Theodore and ela
this one's on shredder use card and boom
there you go you're buying stuff online
safely securely no threat no reoccurring
over his charges no b.s that's the power
of privacy take it back BAE BAE if you
go to privacy calm slash h3 as a special
treat for our viewers new customers will
automatically get five dollars to spend
on your first purchase for a limited
time only
that's free freakin money at privacy
calm /h three it's free money you guys
seen that free real estate name of Tim
and Eric's and free money
forget real estate privacy calm /h three
you got five dollars do get some talk
about something man on us on the house
teddy fresh fall collection is here and
who better to model it than the fine and
beautiful ela Quine the designer and
creator herself of teddy fresh Wow look
at her rocking that dog like an
accessory shredder is wearing the color
black hoodie dog edition ela and a newly
cropped female top never-before-seen
female top she got a brand-new purple
wear new hair teddy fresh looking slick
beautiful outrageous and courageous ela
thank you so much
up next we've got Dan on deck rolling
and wow that's an egg heads are better
than one just do the math folks it's
simple Dan looking good should let's see
the belt ken oh my goodness a teddy
fresh belt is finally here keep those
pants up and look good doing it what's
that hat and black we're new here Teddy
fresh established 2018 wait there's more
there's something underneath that
sweater is there not what now that's a
reveal this striped logo tee with the
bear patch classic beautiful luscious as
good as it gets and could it look better
on Dan Noah couldn't thank you Dan we're
so so proud of him up next we've got
always Paul he's dark he's sultry it's
Zack this sound guy who's celebrating
his one-year anniversary with us I can
hardly believe it
dark Till's the look today PF logo let's
see the sleeve
oh what's that saying teddy fresh he's
got the pants he's got the sleeve he got
the purple hat it's all happening but
wait what's this the hoodie and the same
color hold on like Superman he
disappears only to re-emerge and his
superhero outfit he is back in the TF
classic hoodie with the embroidery with
the candy cane freakin doodles on the
what he's called ela drawcord and
looking good how do you feel Zack
fresh he says thank you Zach
congratulations on one year we love you
next up we have you know he's
fashionable you know he's hip you know
he's always got his ear to the
grindstone it's in the end time too cool
for school wearing white like his soul
is pure his outfit is pure look at the
look it's beautiful it's bold it's
outrageous looking fresh and clean never
quitting in the intern but hold on he's
got to go fight some crime like Superman
hops into a phonebook real fast Dean
Dean and thanks miss never quits like
mr. clean he's coming in fresh to clean
your grimy kitchen clean Ian then turn
folks looking good looking great oh but
wait the look continues oh look who's
back II look climb and the patchwork
hoody this is a look that I am so proud
of I'm in so press back this is a
technical masterpiece it's one of my
favorite pieces you've ever made got the
patchwork hoody and what colors that
this is sunrise she's got the shorts
looking good let me see that ass girl
but pretty good in those shorts give me
a twirl would you and what's up girl
damn and shredder of course I mean come
on
shredder is what he's so cute ridiculous
get out of here yellow and finally
finally finally dan is back a wardrobe
change
he's got the block the teddy fresh
circle shirt looking good looking
fan-fucking-tastic and yes I am dropping
f-bombs because I'm so enthused by this
great look and these fantastic models
dan thank you for working it and finally
you know how you got to end it off what
up Twitter world finds a fresh muse
ethan klein is that's how you wear
clothing
I mean that's amuse you got a tuck you
gotta be extra thick to tuck you gotta
wear extra-large you gotta be extra
large extra in charge and everything is
gonna look great on you
that's how we do it we don't mess around
with regular models who cares about
those this is the real future guys
body-positive extra calorie positive
coloring positive the real teddy bear
behind 30 fresh that's the future of
modeling Tyra Banks would be all about
it you're really working anything
now that's create everything you gotta
go on top model that's it thanks for
watching and we hope you like our new
collection and showing it
how long were we on a card I feel like
if that happens again you should just
you one of you guys should host mm-hmm
that's true the card is weird people are
like I'm out
[ __ ] this card was there a card there
was a card the hell five seconds of it
five seconds - we lost like half our
viewers what happens when you have a
break that's too long you you assumed oh
you got so much time with my MB it up
hope you guys enjoyed the fashion show
even shredder made an appearance anyways
welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
extravaganza experience the
transcendental experience the one and
only jeremy renner this is the guy that
plays Hawkeye and the Avengers which we
can all agree is the shittiest member of
the Avengers like nobody even [ __ ]
cares about Hawkeye am I wrong like I
don't even know why Hawkeye is there you
know that really just has a [ __ ] bow
dude that's so wack
you're fighting next to Thor and Hulk
and all you have is a [ __ ] bow he
doesn't have superpowers does he I mean
he shoots the boat bro he wears a
[ __ ] tunic it's so stupid
he wears it to net dude in the last one
he used a sword too so he's got a sword
annabelle like I love how like uh you
know like the invasion of all these
crazy flying robot things and homies
taking it on this like 500 foot flying
robot monster and he's fighting it with
a bow and arrow you guys next to Thor
with a lightning charged war hammer
forged in the centre of a dying heart a
dying stars heart and you've got to do
with the bow and arrow he's by far the
shittiest adventurer correct me if I'm
wrong because I feel like I'm not in
you guys correct me here I mean I feel
like lamb or one just a guess
archives what what what is your thing
Hawkeye Hawkeyes a fictional superhero
appearing and Marvel Comics yadda yadda
yadda
oh he first appeared as a villain well
[ __ ] him in the first Avengers like
everyone's like babies for hours I want
to know that really good eyeballs dude
they didn't even say that though they
don't even use his super vision in the
movies he's just some dude in a tunic I
don't even I don't think that's accurate
so he's good with the bow and arrow
skills and abilities let's see you
Hawkeye has no superhuman powers he is
at the very peak of human conditioning
you're next before human conditioning
can't take you that far bro he is at the
very peak of human addition he's an
exceptional fencer Wow he's good with a
rapier uh he's an acrobat and marksman
having trained from childhood in the
circus dude this guy sucks he sucks so
anyway yeah that confirms my suspicions
and so but apparently this guy has a fan
club okay he made an app for himself
called the jeremy renner app it's
literally just a social media platform
just for him and his fans there's like
Instagram but he's the only person on it
truly the most bizarre thing ever and of
all the people it's this guy right
that's the thing that's specifically
weird about it like it's not Thor or
Superman or you know the rock people
like the rock
it's Hawkeye who has no super national
powers okay so let's get into this the
home feet is just Jeremy's posts it was
hijacked by trolls Casey Anthony for
example is a frequent troll who
currently has the top had the top post
before it was
he would decided to delete the app Casey
Anthony's a mom who killed her daughter
Oh
and they keep post logically alleged I
don't know yeah
allegedly and they keep posting pictures
of her and their daughter saying like
hey I'm a huge fan dad has a small
problem with people who created profiles
through fake Jeremy Renner Facebook
accounts so they look like Jeremy people
started impersonating him
you can spend a hundred dollars on the
Jeremy Renner stars that you can boost
your post and possibly have it seen by
Jeremy and also it was just posting his
own pictures yes and he was making money
from this he there's somebody who
boosted their post on 999 times what all
right that's a hundred thousand dollars
no thousand times 100 no I think I think
one boost is a dollar so I think it's
999 dollars so a lot well it says that
oh you can I see you can spend up to
$100 yeah you can buy like it's it's
basically it's like micro transact
you know it's Xbox so if your post isn't
good enough if you make a [ __ ] post and
you want it to be on the front anyway
you can just pay to have it there like
so many trolls well right that was one
reason another reason was that they just
used Facebook integration to create
profiles so people just started making
fake profile accounts and linking it and
then it would draw the name and profile
picture and the big one is that they
didn't blacklist Jeremy Renner as a name
so just a million fake Jeremy Renner's
started appearing sorry everyone's
called Jeremy because I feel like
there's probably a limitation on the
Facebook API where you either get it or
right you know what I mean yeah they
couldn't filter yeah I mean I don't know
though there's probably a way so here's
some screenshots here's the app logo you
look Jeremy Renner
I mean how did what so we're gonna dude
makes this yeah I I was thinking maybe
he made it and like as a joke but you're
it's a 100 percent honest which you'll
feel see there's more what the [ __ ] is
this why is there a forehead in this one
you guys hold this someone's phone that
somebody's looks like I shop on their
phones here's the landing page this is
the loading screen well this is the
loading screen what who does who how
could you actually make something like
this for yourself here's one of his
posts happy Ren's day he said they'll
come Jae Ren's by the way here's a
comment by Jeffrey Epstein
hey Jeremy I just got out from cage and
they have put me why you might much
other get hey Jeremy I have just got out
from the cage that they have put me on
we should collab later you could suck my
dick and I could suck yours it's not
even a good troll it's just stupid look
at this number one fan number two friend
yeah these are people who bought stars
yeah you see this so that amount of
stars how much money they really yeah
yeah Wow wait does this mean that
there's no weird does this mean there's
841 dollar spin on this post
looks like it what oh dude this guy's
just raking it in from this what a weird
way to make money as a Hollywood star I
mean you're already hawk I don't like
dude you're already making mine from in
the shittiest adventure don't push a
dude you know jeremy renner net worth
just edit curiously 50 milli the
students point him like a couple
thousand and the yeah and the thing is
he's not even I mean he's known for the
avengers obviously but he's a big actor
aside from that and he was nominated for
an Oscar a few years ago you know like
he doesn't need this extra cash this
picture maybe so this is Casey Anthony
Gila it's honestly really no but this
was the top post
said it says Camp Casey cot candid photo
time
hey jeremy renner I'm your biggest fan
so was my kid hope you didn't [ __ ]
awful then Epstein's back
hey Jeremy I just got out from oh this
is the same one happy wrens date to you
Sharon love Jeff free from my private
island
come on wishes Jeffrey Epstein a happy
Wednesday
you know what's crazy about this too is
with all these people spending money on
the Stars all of these posts heat cross
posted to Instagram like you can get all
this content for free yeah there's
probably some exclusives no I I saw make
a video for the app that I'll watch
later but you know look at this this is
the connect with two times no I mean
Ward nominee Jeremy I'm just reading
this article with the app developer
friendly this company works with many
influencers and a lot of a lot of
celebrities have this know I can't
believe he said out of the five hundred
and full answers that we've worked that
we're working with we've never had a
case of any apps being hurt like this
this is a freak situation
not anymore baby a my concern about this
not more than I'm concerned about 50
other things I'm dealing with no the the
app developer dude you got an issue here
here by the way so so on this post the
Casey Anthony one ela he comments he
goes to everyone criticizing my app
because Casey Anthony has created an
account and is posting on the fan page
spare me your tears this is an all
inclusive app if you don't like it you
heard free to leave that was a big
Jeremy Renner all-inclusive so fight
here Josh Brolin
number one friend
very handsome perhaps you can [ __ ] me
handsome but it's like just a total [ __ ]
show italian jeremy renner
what [ __ ] posting pictures of pasta
Mamma Mia
make it Avengers and then I eat it is
rigatoni that's crazy that people spend
money on this fake one
I shouldn't exist man this should not
exist here's a picture of Wario versus
uh waluigi Wario has no nipples in the
new Olympic game I wonder what jeremy
renner would think about this and he
commented very cool so as you can see it
was it was quite out of control and and
sadly I've got so much good troll
footage in it sadly Eva this is goodbye
wow this one had 30 thousand stars dude
the final goodbyes I love them there's
like a photo shopped for the goodbye
he said stylized because he says the app
has jumped the shark literally do too
clever individuals it's not that not
ever yeah yes not what that's literally
the worst the wrong use of the word
literally how can I even jump the shark
Jeremy literally it's not it doesn't
have a physical body dude but but due to
clever individuals that were able to
manipulate ways to impersonate me and
others within the app I have asked
escape escape ex that's the company the
company that runs this app to shut it
down immediately and refund anyone who
has purchased any stars over the last 90
days
oh wow that's when the trolling started
what was supposed to be a place for fans
to connect with each other has turned
into a place that everything I detest
and can't and won't condone my sincere
apologies brothers to have not turned
out the way it was intended to all the
super fans who have supported me with
your words and encouragement amazing
our stories and times shared a genuine
thank you and I hope to see one
Instagram Twitter YouTube and Facebook
signed jr. don't you feel like this font
is not fitting for this okay there look
so Corinne he signed it like his junior
or Tolkien or something you know I mean
here's the kind of post he would do keep
rockin four thousand stars
[Music]
mood like what's bro
here's another one whoa want to train
are you what do you want to [ __ ] me he's
holding up in the woods but he's not
grace is dressed for like he's going to
middle school first day of middle school
yeah
it's wearing like a open flannel here's
my posted a octopus being pulled on a
leash maybe in bella thorns a clip from
her video belle dolphin yeah what did I
say these people if you look at then
they started posting anti-troll content
if you are a troll move on find the
underside of a bridge and some billy
goats too scared dad get off this app
and then somebody posted a picture of
the twin towers and enduring freedom
from Tony dick-sucker this this is too
ripe to be trolled like I don't know bad
in the slightest bit man not even the
slightest bit when I see a troll on
jeremy renner app no troll zone keep
moving
look at this standing shower [ __ ] I see
a lot dude there's nothing yeah I don't
think it's kids I'll tell you that
I really don't and then finally there
was a video so this is the kind of
explicit
this is the kind of exclusive content
you can expect from the jeremy renner a
nap hey guys jeremy renner here i want
to thank all you superfans on this
fantastic together fan sad
brother you know how I get no he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about them he's shooting a
vertical video like could you put last
working Larry's is just on their way to
doing something else
exactly he's like next to a [ __ ]
power generators hey guys fantastic you
guys are really fantastic
[Music]
Chad coming out and this ad you'll get
to see that
it was pretty exciting
much love that's a she should do wrong
that was epic download going fanclub now
how a pic of an exclusive message was
that so they have it
poor unfortunately to all the fans of
jeremy renner the app has been shut down
permanently because of those goddamn
internet trolls feel bad for all the J
Ren heads out there Jaron Casey and top
post of all time come the Jeremy Renner
app this is a bizarre story not I feel
like the trolling was less bizarre than
the existence of that yeah you know
that's shock the hell out of me other
big news coming out of YouTube lots of
big news coming into YouTube lately but
this one is probably the big one of the
biggest ones I've seen YouTube was fined
by the FTC one hundred and seventy
million dollars for violating children's
privacy collecting data from them
without their parents permission so
apparently there's a law to protect
children from being advertised to mm-hm
because they say rightfully so that kids
cannot distinguish the difference
between an advert and content they don't
know when they're being marketed to and
therefore it's inappropriate to market
to kids and to collect data and to use
them kind of to as a selling point
because I know that on YouTube for
example the kids market is the most
valuable market like on a good on a like
the best month I'll get like $3 CPM
that's like my best month ever kids
content I'm talking 10 do you want to
explain CPM for yeah so that's that's
how many dollars you get per thousand
views essentially on your channel and
it's based on auctioning it's based on
demand so because so many people are
betting on views for kids content
apparently because it's so valuable what
you just link me down it's it's not
relevant to the YouTube thing but I'm
kind of blown away what what I just
found
oh he is an app for the sake of an app
holy [ __ ] I feel like is isn't so
masturbatory though here's that here's
the hey guys what's up I'm in New
Hampshire and my wanted to say that last
time I was here I didn't sell this place
out and now this year I'm here and I did
sell it out and I wanted to thank you
for always listening and watching and
now coming to the shows it just means a
lot to me so I just want to say thanks
to all you guys I know my guys who have
my hat and [ __ ] like that New York I
don't want you to know yeah we're
looking up this company also their name
is escape ex don't you figure they're
trying to sound like SpaceX okay hold on
I can see a list of all these [ __ ]
yeah bro what is with these I gotta make
one of these and just totally make it
like outrageous no I'm not doing that
that's such a waste of time yeah here's
I put a link to their website and we
don't at people but I guess that's
probably the same but it's not see this
just a random fox like I want to see
sorted by popular like I don't know any
of these yeah I was on that YouTube
video for for Jay wrens
and just clicked on there their video
tab in the way immediately saw Chris
D'Elia there oh here we go dude Chris
what I just don't understand then like
you they ask you to be like humorless
for some reason to like be genuine this
is a place to genuinely connect with
fans so many people have it but worse
famous I want to see like what famous
people are on this a lot of things are
famous and I don't know some people do
you know who am are zoning is ela
what about Rhea Riki's what about the
back
that kid backpack is on here yeah second
row top left
oh my [ __ ] god get the back pocket
download that of me this was dicey
Chloe's that Chloe Kardashian
I saw Chloe yeah I don't know that's
what it means we're up at the top let's
go all the way up second row middle oh
she's the worst Kardashian by far who
the hell would follow her oh yeah in
saying that's not that's not the
Kardashian okay he's the authority I
mean their their time is worth so much
money I if they were gonna do this they
do it themselves you know they turn into
some kind of crazy business yeah I don't
know this is a weird thing I can't
believe so many people I gotta find out
from having their own I gotta I get it
next time Chris is on here's Chris
D'Elia
make a note I really gotta talk to him
about this yeah we got to find out more
about this [ __ ] hey guys I just want to
say thank you so so much for connecting
and believing in me I know this is
vertical they asked me to do vertically
cuz it feels more candid and real well
maybe it's vertical because you see it
on your phone so that kind of makes
sense it's more vertical and real bitter
you know what I mean that's true it's
working on your phone no is this grant
that makes absolute sense I don't know
anything [ __ ] people are somehow is
just Chris huh it's just Chris D'Elia
there's definitely an odd stand out from
everybody else on yeah I got Tommy Chong
on there yeah I saw that too
a man hey guys I just want me to say my
accents all over the place thank you
guys for yeah Chris D'Elia what the [ __ ]
dude we gotta talk about amber Rose's
pretty famous she's got it
she's shameless mm-hmm yeah but is she
for what what has she done
I don't know she could say the same
thing about you
I'm on a podcast I have a podcast so
that's something I've done I literally
don't know one thing she's done a model
and actress okay tell me more what have
you been in she dated Kanye West for two
years exactly that's not a thing dude
what's happened the moment you [ __ ]
Kanye West we become famous like this
girl [ __ ] her two years ago and she's
living off residual thing and you seem
I'm saying like I gotta suck that guy's
dick oh she oh she's married to Wiz
Khalifa she was on the Eric Andre show I
remember that episode yeah oh she dated
21 savage - what did you do this girl
just [ __ ] black rappers she's that's
her specialty she has a type yeah rich
black dudes is her type
sorry and she's out of your league Ian
what would you think if you had a chance
to have sex with a girl who slept with
Kanye would you consider that a benefit
[Music]
[Laughter]
genuinely curious we did start talking
about I know I kind of have to start
over and okay such a tangent yeah I
apologize for us no no it was a good I'm
just glad I saw that so where was I I
was talking about there's a law that you
can't market to kids and YouTube I guess
has been violating that law because they
allow targeting ads on kids content take
for example the most popular kids
channel one of the most popular channels
on YouTube itself
Ryan's toy review now this channel is
made look at it obviously for kids so
when advertisers are served ads on this
and YouTube is giving you data and info
they're saying hey that's a violation of
this child protection and advertisement
law so YouTube has been fined 170
million bucks and now they're also being
forced
to make enormous changes to the platform
for example in the next four months
pretty much all YouTube kids content is
gonna be largely demonetised deep
monetize dude that's in Sain that is so
much money that's gonna evaporate off
the plat means they're just not gonna
make videos why would they people who
make kids yeah there's there's literally
no reason other than for love of the
game but maybe that's not even enough
because for example they say in four
months we will treat data from anyone
watching kids content on YouTube as
coming from a child regardless of the
age of the user this means that we will
limit data collection and use on videos
made for kids only to what is needed to
support the operation of the service we
will stop serving personalized ads on
this content also some features will no
longer be available like comments and
notifications not craters will be
required to tell us when their content
falls into this category will also use
machine learning to find those that are
clearly targeting young audience we have
these we for example like the ads that
run before a video yeah that's what
they're talking about so like a like a
toy company yes
he's targeting specifically that because
they know kids are watching right and so
they're not allowed to do that basically
you can no longer specifically buy ads
on kids content on YouTube huh
and the reason the CPM was so high is
because there's so much competition
because it's such a valuable market that
that when people so many bid on it goes
up to ten dollars where maybe ours is
like one two or three depending on the
year mm-hmm so it's very interesting I
didn't know that that was a lot but it
makes sense the more you think about it
it does make sense and I think it was
intended more for like I don't know I
guess the internet maybe I don't know
but I think YouTube was certainly just
kind of hoping no one would go there you
know I just wonder where does it start
and
does it end like how do you define
exactly what's its in that criteria it's
an age there's like they say another
like 8 it's 13 actually up to 1313 like
what about Jake Paul's videos with by
the merch you know so anything got kids
watching I don't think they say well
here they they specifically say creators
will be required to tell us when their
content falls into this category will
also use machine learning fun bibs that
clearly target young audience for
example those that have an emphasis on
kids characters themes toys or games
okay so they will probably categorize
his as teen teenager okay but they
certainly wouldn't have kids adverts on
it and I think that's the big issue
right so that that's the law that they
got fined on wasn't specifically that
they were advertising to kids it was
that they were collecting data right
they were there well the data they were
collecting was was to use for
advertising was was basically yeah it's
connected because advertisers came on
the platform and they said I want to
serve ads to kids and I thought well how
did they get that through the data
exactly so it's that has made all this
now impossible and so by disabling
interest-based ads people can no longer
target them and I don't know who's who
checks not interest based as because you
don't know where it's gonna end up like
who doesn't target their ads at all if
you want to say male/female age bracket
geographical location I don't think
there's gonna be much money there it's
just gonna be a really weird cheap [ __ ]
interesting yeah dude it's super weird
so there's no incentive financial
incentive and their views are gonna be
hamstrung now - because notifications
and comments are being disabled on all
this content it's a huge huge change
yeah I wonder if it will affect I've
been trying to tell you - for so long I
make content for adults 18 the 35 male
is our primary demographic
well yeah it's like 75 25 yeah and I
always say YouTube
that's the most valuable a cross-section
in traditional media why the [ __ ] don't
you guys care about us it's cuz they're
all the money was in kids and they were
breaking the [ __ ] law
- oh yeah I wanted to show you guys this
bro you want to see some crazy [ __ ] 1.8
billion yes that's a B 1.8 billion you
want to see what this dumb [ __ ] video
is it's not even interesting or unique
or huge egg surprise 1.8 billion or
they're gonna claim us yeah we're gonna
need to because they're just for this
app the audios ass
I don't know how I don't this sounds so
weird how did they put their kid up to
doing all this code I gave it to this
day this is doing all this yeah they buy
them all the crazy [ __ ] yeah this is
gonna end up like the question is how
he's gonna feel about it when he's older
right you're not actor he's a child
actor I mean actually so sexually I give
him about he's probably let me just put
it this way if Michael Jackson was
around he'd be friends with this kid you
may feel some negativity towards it but
assuming his parents are following the
law when he turns 18 he's gonna have
Millions
what a lot all that damn cuz this is a
child actor exactly this is YouTube does
it apply there's a bunch of kids who
like their parents ran off with their
fortune which is oh it used to happen
Hollywood a lot and so write down and
they're required to pay money in a trust
I feel like my parents would do that to
me it's called the Coogan law oh yeah
how come you're so knowledgeable about
the Coogan studying entry along the
keggle laws my parents would totally do
that to me they'd be like it's for your
college fund and then I turn 18 I'm like
they're like yeah we paid for college
I'm like what about like the 30 million
ounce to be like we paid for your calls
you can be happy anyway this has almost
one point nine sorry please I issue a
correction one point nine billion to be
flabbergasted by that but so channels
like this now this is where it gets
really interesting for me too
is that wait I think I
so channels like this one the FTC is
saying they're going to be targeting as
well because they estimated a media
group estimated that 90% of all of their
videos are sponsored with well here this
guy exactly right this guy led explain
who sponsored videos that often have the
look and feel of organic content
according to truth in advertising nearly
90% of the ryan toysreview videos have
included at least one paid product
recommendation aimed at preschooler a
group that they say is too young to
distinguish between a commercial and a
review and that distinguish argument is
one of the key things here as explained
in a New York Times article on the Josh
Colin who's the executive director of
the campaign for a commercial-free
childhood support Lee said many children
do not recognize advertising until they
are eight or nine years old some videos
on YouTube channels like ryan toysreview
have noted sponsored content and small
type that appears briefly he said or
through a voiceover thank you to the
retailer or manufacturer that provided
products a gallon goes on to argue a
five-year-old isn't going to understand
that Ryan's talking about the toys
because target is paying him to talk
about the toy is there may be some
disclosure but disclosure isn't
meaningful to a child that young now as
far as the other side of this Ryan's
father released a statement so they're
going after the individual channels now
to which is pretty crazy yeah but I but
it does kind of raise an interesting
point I mean 90% of his videos are
sponsored mm-hmm and they're they fit
organically into the video it's not like
like on our Park when we have sponsors
we go thank you to honey or whatever did
it at it up there clearly a sponsor but
here it's all what they would call like
integrated ads where it's like I'm
playing with this play-doh brand who
paid me on if you put a little link a
little title at the top of the video a
kid wouldn't really understand what that
works for someone like me who wants yeah
close that I have a copy read and a
sponsor but yeah it's very true I mean
at this level the level that their
channel is
these guys get like 300 million views
these guys are like a multi dude these
guys probably make at least 50 million
dollars a year this is like a huge
machine list of the top yeah
earning channels right
are they number one number one they were
exactly they made so at that level you
have lawyers you have people I mean
these guys are well familiar with the
law you wanna have something crazy
though I just looked it up the Coogan
law that's actress brought up doesn't
apply to youtubers yeah exactly I mean
the not and not accusing that maybe
they're great and they are you know
setting inside a ton of money for their
kid when he grows up but they're not
required to they could just spend it I
was I met Brad at YouTube creator
students you seem like a sweet a normal
nice girl I mean obviously I met him
prove that or no I'd be surprised if
they did that but again just the
possibility right there's no protection
it's just leaving it to them being good
people so ryan toysreview channel made
22 million and it was the number one
earning channel of 2019
what they made more than 22 million if
it's number one I made like seventy
million dollars last year no no I did I
saw this a CBS News article is this just
from the revenues that might not be
counting their their integrations I
don't know how they come into the number
exactly but they have like Logan Paul at
14 million PewDiePie at 15 million must
just be the Adsense I saw one that was
like adjusted for merch and stuff it
says they're taking into account their
video advertising merchandise deals and
other sources of revenue so I just
thought they would be making more than
that well anyway that's a lot of money
clearly million yeah yeah well anyway so
this channel is the number one they're
number one regardless and so they
certainly are familiar with the law
there's no way you make that much money
and you don't know
your industry in and out and your legal
liabilities 0% chance of that so that'll
be interesting to see how that plays out
I'm sure they're hedging their bets
they're like dude whatever fine we get
same for YouTube they paid a hundred and
you know 70 million bucks dude they
probably made billions not billions but
hundreds of millions I saw an article
estimate that one hundred nine hundred
seventy million dollar fee is less than
their revenue in one day a single day
really you know way from YouTube not
Google YouTube probably Google yeah
Google that makes sense
YouTube is a different yeah um but
anyway
interesting stuff so I wonder how that's
gonna affect us and wonder if that's
gonna increase our CPM as the pool
decreases but I don't think toy sores
are necessarily gonna want to promote
you know hot wheels on our podcast but
if they can't target they can't target
we can't target kids it's just general
they could target anyone but kids they
could target parents they could target
yeah they could target parents we got
parents I'm a parent mm-hmm you want to
advertise Hot Wheels I'm here and it's
all legal baby all legal all day all the
time if you look in the banner of the
Ryan's toy review YouTube channel he
looks like he's as a Nickelodeon show
yeah I saw that
there's correct baby boy that FTC
complaint so there you have it what do
you think you uh I cannot believe it
this is gonna be another one of those
big changes and then people will be like
remember the days when when you can make
kids content when you become a
billionaire some of those family
channels are huge the biggest there's
huge I mean Ethan Bradberry for Christ's
sake used to be Ricky and the kids
though yeah you know the world's ass
backward when Tennessee TV and Ethan
Bradberry can make hundreds of thousands
of dollars entertaining kids but there's
the truth is that there's so many
bizarre weird
twisted kids content that's been on
there for so long and this is gonna
outright stop all that because these
people are only motivated by money money
and they said we're establishing a
hundred million dollar fund to start
dispersed over three years dedicated to
the creation of thoughtful original
children's content on YouTube so they
want to keep the market but I guess they
gotta just fun to themselves yeah
they'll just kind of turn into their own
Nickelodeon basically mmm but I wonder
how they're gonna make money from that
maybe they'll have a premium service you
know but um I think it's probably a good
thing and inevitable everyone made his
money for as much they made as much
money as they could before they knew
they were gonna get shut down and now
everybody's over and I'm still here
YouTube's waiting for it a little
recognition I ain't breaking the law you
know I find it funny that's like the
ultimate hypocrisy of YouTube like if
you look at the CEOs of YouTube and
Google they're like the most socially
conscious social justice warrior people
on the planet yet when it comes to
child's privacy they're like oh well we
are socially conscious but when it comes
to making money I'll [ __ ] saw these
stupid little [ __ ] any [ __ ]
day that's a billion dollars [ __ ] you
I'll break the law I just it's really
like that I just wonder if it's really
like that and how well sure they
rationalize it but at the end of the day
they their lawyers sure as [ __ ] know
they're they're gonna they're breaking
the law you know what I mean I'm sure
they in their mind they try to be
conscious about it but they're like hey
this guy wrote a memo that the people
were offended by so we're gonna fire him
and make a bit whole big bub about
promoting you know LGBTQ creators but in
the meantime we're gonna make a billion
dollars violating children's privacy I
swear to god it's like it's all PR you
know at the end of the day their
business they're looking to make money
that's the number one priority it's
there there you there Google they their
business is sucking money like a vacuum
did you know and their main business is
your data and that is the product but
the truth is that you look at the CEO of
YouTube Susan Wojcicki she's a super
sweet super nice down-to-earth very woke
mm-hmm woman I mean I've I've met with
her personally a couple of times and
spent some time with them which is why I
don't know if it's like use but this is
the Google guy this is the guy who
really pulls the [ __ ] the strings this
is the CEO of Google and this guy's some
super wok young Indian dude who doesn't
[ __ ] around
but in this guy sat in an office with a
bunch of people was like we're gonna
serve these [ __ ] little spineless
idiots their brains don't even work when
this chef Hot Wheels so far down their
throat they're gonna be [ __ ] golden
eggs for us is he now he's the CEO of
Google mm-hmm I guess I think
technically the CEO of alphabet would be
YouTube's boss well when this got a CEO
of Google before alphabet happened I see
okay so I think he's he probably has a
lot of Larry Page was that it oh is this
Larry Page yeah I think Larry Page he's
the big boy yeah this guy doesn't [ __ ]
around yeah
Larry Page will [ __ ] you'll you'll
wake up in a creek if you [ __ ] with
Larry Page fifty three billion fifty
four billion this is a guy that made
Google co-founder of Google how is it
that all these like artists that make
these crazy tech companies end up being
like the best CEO also like Mark
Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos Larry Page they
made this really obscure crazy
technology and I say artists because
they probably all are on the scale I
mean look at them they're really awkward
tech I mean you're on the spectrum on
the spectrum yeah on the spectrum and I
don't mean that as a joke I mean they're
genuinely and then they all end up being
like like look at Mark Zuckerberg that
guy's definitely on the spectrum they
all end up being like these extremely
successful CEOs how's that possible
well I don't think being autistic
necessarily means you're not good
no I mean not being a big part not the
artistic part the part about like I'm
gonna make a little tech company and
then it's gonna go wildly successful and
now I'm gonna be the CEO of the biggest
company in the world it's interesting
how you go from being a little tech
startup to being like the CEO the
biggest moment sometimes it works out I
would argue them I mean I don't think
they planned on anything it's just it's
just it's interesting that they were
able to you said yeah they're geniuses I
guess that's why their company succeeded
from the beginning Mark Zuckerberg is
he's got to be a phenomenal CEO I mean
he [ __ ] he's one of I mean look
facebook is huge yeah they've just had a
lot more missteps over the years then
yeah then Google has you know since yeah
certainly since since they've gotten so
big yeah I mean he's definitely on the
scale probably pretty high up the scale
if I'm being honest good the suck yeah I
mean who knows but from the videos of
him yeah he's a well anyway
again I'm not I'm not
dear-dear writing is that the right word
let me look that up right now I'm making
an official statement
yeah I'm not deriding autistic people
I'm all I'm saying what am i doing
nobody cares who cares you know what I
meant either you know what I meant or
you don't doesn't matter what I say
and anyway look he's smoking meets the
suck owns like half of Hawaii apparently
mm-hmm good smoky flavor good job on
those Zak and I know you cut up the sock
like that we've had that in the pocket
for a while finally
let's see you I wanna I'm curious to
hear Larry Page talk what does this guy
sound like just a good sense of not
getting on camera like the suck wants to
be like a superstar you know I mean the
suck livestreams himself smoking meats
yeah what do we got we got a TED talk
with Larry Page that sounds boring worth
the end of this show nobody's watching
I'm just want to hear what Larry Page
sounds like yeah all right Larry and
what do you got for us I hate it when
people say somebody needs no
introduction then goes on to introduce
him
so don't but wait
that was so awkward why are these people
so awkward Brooke don't say it if you're
gonna do it right I gotta watch this
again I hate it when people say somebody
needs no introduction then goes on to
introduce them but I do wanna start in
the realm of what might have been just
go I think 1997 Larry and Sergey almost
no it's not going down how the world
might be different if that had in fact
happened we had Larry say simply I'm
here for you
life is cooler sauce do the ventures but
you know either subsidized bro talk
Larry I'm here for used power who is
this guys that's the other co-founder
Kai's dad
yeah I was talking go ahead here we got
home anyway I don't think my always
likely got much worse I'm happy about
that
oh he's got the boys so I'm hanging on
every word Larry what do you got for me
and it's and it's priced at 182 dollars
a month
[Laughter]
he's moderating himself you lost your
voice what you learned from that okay
nice cut yeah I mean it was great sir he
encouraged me he just said he lost his
voice and he's asking about that
experience we're going through this
whole video to hear his voice and like
this isn't his normal voice because he's
got like the worst video we could that
was a lot of feedback and information
and things like that good okay so here's
a good example I think you know we're
talking about medicine but a lot of you
know the things mr. go-go about cause
it's medical issues America somehow
worked ourselves into a state around
that someone parsley I don't care very
much about that so I don't have that
issue but I think wow what would you do
it 50 million mmm-hmm
how much he's worth ya know you're
asking yeah he's worth 50 billion what
would you guys do with 50 billion I have
no idea in yeah by a country should I
mean by a country what can you buy a
country for 50 bit would you do one tree
why not
sovereignty baby pretty trying what do
you need with sovereignty damn god Jay
understand power even they do need
sovereignty are people that can't do
legally here what they
do I'll tell you what I would do with 50
billing I would donate it all to charity
all right let's [ __ ] let's get out of
here
TGIF mother effers I'm so tired dude oh
I heard um
Christina's podcast about she has the
new um where my mom is that my god
mm-hmm and she just said like I'm so
tired I haven't slept in four years like
there's two other kids
mm-hmm I thought that was so funny
that's how I feel now all the time it's
like that's it I sometimes have thoughts
like that where I'm like I don't think
I'm ever gonna get like a normal night's
sleep
yeah like five years or maybe even
longer maybe longer yeah and then I
think why do we do this and we got
another dog and I shits even crazier at
her house and I'm like what do we did
like what are we doing but then like
when we have went it always smiling at
us and we're all having fun then I don't
you lose trying to put a silver lining
on it
well I because I don't really think that
it's just when you're like tired you're
like what have I done
yeah I'm not seriously considering a
control out the leading back to a
previous save if I had the technology I
mean the technology exists we could
discuss it but I don't have an option
but I mean it's like you in all day it's
like that you go back and forth yeah now
you have you have we still have some
moments our quiet moments it's been
working we go okay we have two hours and
then we end up working and then we
wanted to watch bachelor in paradise but
now we're at a time
mm-hmm so I have to stay up till 3:00 to
watch The Bachelor paradise and that
means I'm gonna get like four hours of
sleep because let's go change our
schedule that's the problem I'm gonna
start going to sleep early I just can't
do which I also told that I should go to
sleep early today
but it's so hard for me to go to bed at
10:00 it's just I did it's like the best
time I even like working at night and I
like watching I like drawing at night
like everything I want to do I want to
do at night
Pete's uh what's for dinner tonight
what's for dinner
[Music]
there's like I don't know I wish I had
good that I really crave right now go
ahead called phone cold brew there yeah
coffee from Starbucks all right this is
the end
I'm officially starting to sub bombs
[Music]
that means we're saying goodbye farewell
to all of our fans you can follow me on
the ethan klein app you'll get exclusive
updates and messages from me yours truly
for fans and the show and fans of mine
in general I'm an interesting guy I'm a
fascinating guy you can't get enough of
me and frankly I quite understand if you
didn't get enough for me fast you can go
to my app at even climb app dot-com
download the app there faster from that
point you will have access to my all
exclusive photos videos of me and Ernest
thanking you not being funny serious
thank you only nudes as well tasteful
nude and but most of all just my
beautiful face Photoshop heavily make me
look more handsome than I am but that's
what you want to see right a perfect
life a perfect world a perfect man quite
frankly which I am so head on over to
Ethan client app dot government you can
follow me there you can see me thanking
you and hanging out with my family
god I have to be so bad and just overall
living it up an idyllic life that
frankly couldn't get any better
we are having the correct checks to
avoid being trolled we have moderators
will promptly ban any trolls this is a
troll free zone over at you can climb
out and if you're thinking about coming
in pretending to be Jeffrey Epstein you
can think again because we're not a
Pierrot tolerance policy and the first
troll we see we will erase the app
entirely so don't ruin the fun for
everybody else we have reports that
there is a weaver race that so i guess
that's going guys so that's it have a
good have a good holiday holiday it's
the weekend TGIF [ __ ] records
let's get your dicks out and shake them
and shake them and play some video games
and watch bachelor in paradise and demon
hunts are on Hulu is really good I'm
gonna watch that it's an anime that's
good yeah we've been trying to watch
that for two weeks I've passed you be
like five that's fine and head over
jeremy renner at chris pelea at this
time last year I was a hun 200 pounds
this time I'm to ten head over to Ethan
Happ worth of s alright Dan you know
what to do it's about that time
thank you for buddy thanks for watching
thank you next week
[Music]